[Musique]
bien sûr beaucoup de français sont
partis en vacances sont actuellement en
vacances beaucoup de français sont plus
précisément en vacances sur la côte
bretonne mais il ya également beaucoup
de parisiens qui n'ont pas vu prendre de
vacances et bien qu'ils se consolent car
tout en restant à paris ils peuvent
prendre des vacances bretonnes puisque
au coeur de paris il y à une colonie
bretonne je dirais même mieux capitale
bretonne c'est paris montparnasse
capital à un point tel qu il y a une
ambassade de roatan monsieur
l'ambassadeur wind on passait d'un
consulat dirons nous nous sommes
plusieurs à opérer pour accueillir les
parisiens et ceux qui ne sont pas de
paris ce dîner autour de paris comme nos
compatriotes pour leur parler à nos
bombes adrien de leur parler du pays
s'ils ont le mal du pays aux parisiens
pour leur donner le mal du pays et avoir
envie d'y aller je vous assure il en
part s'il en vient
c'est évidemment l'ambassade c'est le
lieu de rassemblement où l'on respire
déjà la bretagne car la vue des
dépliants touristiques la côte de granit
rose dinan et la rance pleumeur bodou
vous citer quelques fois et cetera que
serre les coudes il alors le plq on a
démoli la l'ancienne gare montparnasse
là par le boulevard de vaugirard
vous avez l'air de bretagne hier le
watan direct donc on peut dire aux
parisiens qui sont au mois d'août à
paris venez respirer la bretagne à
montparnasse un peu des roses au lieu
des gratuits amont par c'est comme ça
que vous appelez la pluie 1
mais il n'y a pas une assiette encore
une légende qu'il faut détruire mais
nous sommes des pays des légendes qu'est
ce qu'on trouve à montparnasse tous les
commerces brosse dans tous les commerces
breton est d'excellente crêperie on peut
goûter déguster me crève l'écran
poussant breton woods le coquillage
autres sillage aussi des coquilles
saint-jacques très bien préparés
pourquoi y at il tant de breton aux
environs de la gare montparnasse
eh bien mon dieu ceci est un phénomène
que l'on doit à l'industrialisation 19e
siècle et la création des chemins de fer
par nos grands pères nous aurions grand
père qui était les terrassiers qui
posait les voies et maintenant ce sont
leurs neveux ou leurs petits enfants qui
sont des ingénieurs et qui les dirigent
évidemment il ya une extension expansion
est vraiment une élévation de la
condition sociale pour beaucoup de nos
compatriotes ont peut dire en quelque
sorte que les bretons ont un excès de
quartier montparnasse ils ont un excès
peut-être paris tout entier mais enfin
disons euros voyez comme ils sont les
bretons avant lui le 18e aussi cette
gamme sont des evées parent que l'église
du coin là notre âme à notre dame et de
notre dame des champs c'est la paroisse
bretonne par excellence qu'est les
pardons et il ya des pardons tous les
ans notamment pour le père mont noir qui
évangélisa la bretagne niveau 12e ou 13e
siècle ils auront la chance d'avoir ici
à la maison de la bretagne des
bretonnants une secrétaire deux
secrétaires qui sont maintenant mais
qu'il travaille pas en costume régional
à ce n'est pas la peine et que vous êtes
ici vous sentez que vous êtes en bon
alors est-ce qu'on peut conseiller aux
parisiens qui regardent la télévision de
venir passer leurs vacances ils peuvent
pas quitter la capitale à paris
montparnasse capitale de la preuve ils
viennent 3 rue du départ à la maison de
la bretagne changer voulais piloter
on les piles et il ya tout et vous avez
y compris du muscadet pour l'aider à
noter et il ya même de la musique de la
musique avec ya une musique bretonne le
barde le bar 2000 mais aux mille bo
alors peut-être si vous voulez pour
terminer sur une note musicale et
bretonne barde nounou cent des quelque
chose en breton et ne nous allons fermer
les yeux tous les deux nous allons
respirer cet air qui arrivent de l'ouest
vancouver gojira bar la colère ou la
plaine marie madrid ne bat murray visera
des broadys cornet irions 6 was made to
cause mais n'a pas tué je me sens vrai
dans son ensemble comme santez anna et 4
3 devant nous
elles sont dix arrivant au mbam vln
on n'a qu'à cuba par el hadary d'eau
énorme
[Musique]